- [Mike] The United States
Air Force Thunderbirds
reached out and asked if I
was ready to fly in an F16.
I reluctantly said yes.
I'm gonna pass out.
I mean, there's no other way about it.
- [Lt. Col.] Blood's just
gonna drain out of your skull.
- [Mike] I'm a little dizzy. If we can...
- [Gator] Okay.
- [Mike] ...take a quick pause.
- [Lt. Col.] You feel like you have
an elephant sitting on your chest.
One, two, three. One, two,
three. One, two, three
- Had to wake up at 4:00 AM.
So you can bet I didn't sleep much.
Even though the explicit instructions
were sleep a good night's sleep.
They also said have a heavy breakfast
or at least a good breakfast.
I had a protein bar. Oh, and a banana.
- We're trying to enter
the air force base.
But apparently they said,
we don't know who you are.
Apparently the Pentagon did
not send our clearance through
to this spot right here.
And because of that, oh
my God, plane landing.
I was afraid to do this.
What was I afraid of you may ask.
Well, the height for one,
the not knowing what it's
gonna feel like, two,
and three, I was worried about G-LOC.
G-force induce loss of consciousness.
Okay. First of all, what is G-Force?
G-Force is a poorly received
2009 Disney film about a team
of secret agent Guinea pigs.
G-Force is also a measurement
of the force of gravity
on our bodies. In everyday life,
we have one G of force on us.
That's the earth's
standard force of gravity.
Our bodies are well acclimated to them.
- So we're going to get
you up to nine Gs today.
A really wicked roller coaster
is like three to four Gs give or take.
At one G, let's say you weigh 200 pounds,
at nine Gs, You can weight 1800 pounds.
Fluids do what gravity tells them to.
In this case the blood is
gonna drain out of your skull.
- [Mike] So as your heart beats
it's trying to have the blood move up
but there's way too much
force pushing it down.
As a result, you don't
get enough circulation.
You don't get enough
oxygen going to the brain.
You G-LOC, you pass out.
- [Instructor] How you feeling, sir?
The only way to fight that?
One, I'm going to be
wearing a very special suit
that helps squeeze my lower
body in order to help push some
of this blood back up into my body.
The second thing is something known
as the anti G-straining maneuver.
- Ready, now. Good, good,
good clench, good clench.
- Basically what I needed to do
learn to squeeze my entire lower body
and try and keep my blood up here.
And you're doing a
breathing technique where
you're exhaling very short
breaths against a closed Glottis.
- One, two, three. One two
three. One, two, three.
- Because if you don't
if you let's say go (exhales)
good luck taking a big, deep breath in.
- You feel like you have an
elephant sitting on your chest.
- This will be the t-shirt
you wear underneath.
This is gonna be your flight suit.
So it's like one big pajama onesie.
- Okay.
- And then these are your boots. Size 11?
- Yup.
- All right.
- They make it sound
so easy. No, it's not.
- [Camera Man] You said
you'll be giggling at nine Gs,
I think.
- [Mike] I somehow don't think that's it.
Wait, didn't she say,
"can't have synthetics on"?
I think I'm wearing synthetic underwear.
I haven't worn boots like
this ever in my life.
I would not make a good soldier.
Everyone who wears this patch,
we have to work our way up to it
So it's an honor to wear this patch
and today you get to wear it.
- Wow.
I am ready to not eject
out of this aircraft.
- Okay, perfect.
- Do you feel like you have a good seal?
- Yes.
- Inhale. Hold. One, two, three, exhale.
Yep. And take the helmet off.
Perfect.
- Cool.
They taught me about the eject lever
in between my legs, but
they also consistently
told me do not pull it unless
you truly need to eject.
Apparently someone in the
past, they were so anxious
being inside the cockpit, they
just pulled it to escape out.
Next walks in Lieutenant
Colonel, Kevin de Falco.
And he tells me everything
we're about to do in this plane.
And I'm not gonna lie, my
anxiety was at an all time high.
I'm gonna pass out.
I mean, there's, there's
no other way about it.
I'm gonna pass out.
- You'll be fine. I promise.
If I can do it, you can do it.
I'm like five one, 150 pounds so...
Yeah. but that makes it better for you.
You're more protected from the G-Force.
- That's true, that's
true. Short and female.
- To be honest, like they sound
very reassuring when they talk to you.
But I think that the
reassurance, maybe one of those,
like make him think he'll
be okay so he will be okay.
So I don't think I'm gonna be okay.
But I might be okay.
(upbeat music)
- [Camera Man] Famous last words?
- This was a bad idea.
(drumline playing)
(radio chatter)
- [Gator] There's afterburner.
There's 100 miles per hour.
There's 150.
We're gonna take off here.
Gears coming up.
There's 250 miles an hour.
Take a breath.
Here come the Gs.
(radio chatter)
All right, so yeah, if you look at the...
We're going about .67 machs,
about 67% the speed of sound.
- [Mike] That's in the bottom left corner.
- [Gator] Bottom left corner, yeah.
303 knots. I can switch
that to ground speed.
We're going 395 miles
per hour ground speed.
1G currently.
Ready to go?
- [Mike] Yup.
- All right, good prep.
Here come the Gs.
- I'm starting to lose my vision.
My heart is working in overdrive
to try and bring the blood
back from my lower body to my brain.
- [Gator] All right, next
we're going into a loop.
You ready to go for the loop?
- [Mike] Okay.
- [Gator] Deep breath.
Here come the Gs.
- Staring inside the cockpit
was a really bad idea.
It causes sensory conflict
between what my eyes were seeing
and what my inner equilibrium was feeling.
As a result, I got really nauseous.
- [Gator] Gonna bring
it all the way through.
We're gonna keep going.
You can see our smoke.
There's our smoke. Look up
and you can see the smoke.
There's our loop, how
about that? Pretty cool!
- [Mike] I'm a little dizzy. If we can...
- [Gator] Okay.
- [Mike] ...take a quick pause.
- [Gator] All right.
- [Mike] Recalibrate here.
- [Gator] Yeah. All right,
we're gonna get down here
and we're gonna do a knife edge next.
- [Mike] Okay.
- [Gator] Ready to go?
- [Mike] Yup.
- [Gator] All right, here we go.
Through the clouds at a 90 degree angle.
Nice and straight.
We're gonna streak down
now, left side, ready?
- [Mike] Yup.
- [Gator] Here we go,
inverted to inverted.
Inverted. We'll hang here.
All right, you ready to roll 360 degrees?
- [Mike] Yeah.
- [Gator] Here we go. Rolling it.
Here we go, inverted again.
Take a look at the
clouds, we're past them.
- [Mike] Yeah.
- [Gator] Good breath.
Here come the Gs.
(suspenseful music)
(cheering and applause)
- He was a little nervous this morning
about what the maneuvers are gonna be like
and how we were gonna do,
but I'll tell you, he got through
the entire profile today.
We did every maneuver.
(cheering and applause)
You guys are probably
curious on what he did
in terms of Gs. He did pull 9.2 Gs.
(cheering and applause)
- It could not have been
done without everyone here.
So I have to give everyone a
huge thank you for allowing me
to participate, this is a
once in a lifetime experience
that I'm gonna be telling
my followers, my patients.
So thank you again.
And thank you, Gator, for
getting me back safely.
- Yeah.
Thanks for keeping
everybody healthy and happy
and inspiring your followers
to live a better life.
That's important to us too.
- [Mike] I was so nervous.
- I know, I was a little worried.
You were so nervous during the briefings.
- Right. After that first
one I knew I could handle it.
Came close to graying out a
couple of times, but I noticed
as I adjusted my muscles
and I wasn't squeezing,
I would say, my abdomen
enough, or my glutes enough.
Once I adjusted, right
away, the vision came back.
Let's get this video to
a 100 thousand likes.
Let's continue our mission with
the United States air force.
Let's see some cool stuff.
Let's see the medical side of it.
Let's see what being a doctor
in the air force is like
- I'm working and flying
everyday with my patients.
- You wanna do that, definitely hit like.
Check out this video of me
saving a life on an airplane,
or this video here where I
actually fly a different airplane
and hold some incredible animals.
Actually interact with the animal.
Like, both are really good watches.
Which one are you going to watch?
As always stay happy and healthy.